علينا مصر والمسؤول في وزاره الطاقه
السعوديه ان المملكه ستقوم بتمديد الخط
التطوعي او الطوعي البالغ مليون برميل
يوميا والذي بدا تطبيقه في شهر يوليو
الجاري ليشمل شهر اغسطس مع امكانيه
تمديدته
مددت السعوديه الخفض الطوعيه الذي اعلنت
عنه الشهر الماضي بمليون برميل يوميا
كل دوله اذ ان هناك العديد من الدول التي
كانت تنتج باقل من حصصها الرسميه بكثير
اكبر انخفاض طال حصه روسيا ب 650 الف
برميل يوميا في المقابل زادت حصه الامارات
ب 200 الف برميل يوميا لتصبح الحصه اكثر
تلائما مع قدرتها الانتاجيه وصرح وزير
الطاقه الاماراتي سهيل المزروعي بعد قرار
السعوديه الاخير بان تحالف اوبل بلس
يستهدف استقرار اسواق النفط ما يجري ديني
العربيه
من الخبر الخبير في استراتيجيات الطاقه
نايف الدندني سيد نايف حياك الله من
الرياض كل عام وانت بخير شهر اضافي من
التمديد
للخفض الطوعي من السعوديه لماذا اولا هل
كانت متوقعه طبقا لظروف السوق الحاليه
المشاهدين والمتابعين بالف خير الحقيقه
كان متوقع وكان
كنا نقرا مثل هذا التمديد بسبب الظروف
التي نشهدها في الاسواق مؤخرا في هناك
ضغوط كبيره على
اسعار النفط واسواق النفط لا علاقه لها
بالاساسيات ولا ولا علاقه لها بالعرض
والطلب ولكنها الحقيقه تاتي من
المخاوف الكبيره التي تاتي من تباطل
الاقتصاد العالمي وارتفاع معدلات الفائده
وفي ظل مثل هذه الاوضاع
الحقيقه الاجراء الامثل هو تقييد الانتاج
بحيث انه يضمن استقرار وتوازن الاسواق
والسعوديه الحقيقه اقدمت على مثل هذه
الخطوه في شهر جولاي الحالي ومدى وتم
تمديده الى شهر
ثمانيه او شهر اوغست القادم هذا
الخفض كيف شفت الانعكاسات الحاليه له على
الاسواق هل لا زال بذات الحساسيه
والله الحقيقه الاسواق بالفتره الاخيره
نايف فقدت حساسيتها المفرطه مثل هذه
التخفيضات لانها ترضخ تحت تاثير شديد من
من مخاوف الركود
تباطؤ الاقتصاد العالمي وبالتالي الحساسيه
المفرطه اللي كنا نشهدها في السابق مثلا
200 الف برميل كانت تؤثر على الاسواق
وممكن انها ترفع الاسعار بمعدل 4 الى 5
دولار مجرد انه يحدث حدث يعطل نتائج
بوضع مئات من من براميل النفط بعض مئات
الالاف من براميل النفط الحقيقه اصبحنا لا
نرى هذه السبايكس بسبب الاوضاع اللي
ذكرتها وبسبب انه في مخاوف على الطلب
وخصوصا
الضبابيه المفرطه التي تاتي من الصين
معدل نمو الاقتصاد الصناعي الان تحت الخمس
ين نقطه وبالتالي غير مشجع خليني اسالك عن
ضبابيه اخرى يمكن انت دائما تعبر فيها في
حساباتك على موقع التواصل الاجتماعي وانا
اتحدث هنا عن روسيا هي ايضا جددت التزامها
بالخفض التطوعي ل 500000 برميل تقريبا حتى
يعني شهر اغسطس ليش انت متحفظ دائما على
هذه الارقام التي تعلن من روسيا
بالتخفيض
نايف التحفظ ياتي من جزئين الجزء الاول هو
معدلات الانتاج ونصف مثل امتثال التي تاتي
من روسيا هل روسيا متقيده تماما بالحصص او
بما يسمى الكوتا المقرره لها من قبل بلس
هناك علامه استفهام وبالتالي والدليل على
ذلك الحقيقه انه نفسها اقرت الان ثلاث
جهات مستقله عن حتى تحقق في معدلات
الانتاج التي تنتجها روسيا ونسب الامتثال
التي اقرت لها من
فعندنا علامه استفهام حول معدلات الانتاج
التي تاتي من روسيا
التحفظ الثاني ياتي من التخفيضات
التخفيضات التي تعطيها بشكل كبير
ولا الهند نعم تخفيضات اسعار على البرميل
الخام الاورال الروسي اللي يتجه الى يتجه
الى الهند اذا كان عندك انت منتج
رئيسي جالس يعطيك باسعار مخفضه ويغرق
الاسواق
باسعار اقل الحق هذا بالتاكيد حيؤثر على
سعر النقطه العالمي في
سعر النفط العالمي وعلى التداول
بما يعني انه مع اي تخفيض قد لا تتغير
الاسعار كثيرا او لا تكون بذات الحساسيه
سابقا يعني عندما كانت ايران عفوا عندما
كانت روسيا طبعا تبيع في اوبر بلس من ضمن
مجموعه طبعا بشكل يعني مكشوف ومعروف من
دون تخفيضات
بالضبط بالضبط الان التخفيضات اللي جالسه
تصير من روسيا هذه تؤثر على الاسواق
والضبابيه حول انتاجها طبعا الضبابيه
حتحلل الان بالمصادر المستقله او الجهات
المستقله عن انه تحقق في انتاجها ونسبه
امتثالها باقي موضوع التخفيضات التخفيضات
في ظل الاوضاع اللي احنا نشهدها في ظله
التباطل الاقتصادي
ونسبه النمو الان الغير واضحه بالنسبه
للصين يمكن الهند بشكل واضح نبوها واضح
بشكل افضل ولكن هذه التخفيضات الحقيقيه
تؤثر على الاسواق العالميه وعلى شهيه حتى
المتداولين السوق الورقيه في التعاملات
الفوريه او حتى في العقود الاجله في
الاسواق النفطيه وبالتالي لها تاثير كبير
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من الخبر الخبير في
استراتيجيات الطاقه نايف الدندنه شكرا
جزيلا لك لمتابعه
المزيد اخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات